I think it's part of human nature to
give how much you give as a matter of
opportunity not necessarily who you are
but the opportunity to see a need and
fulfill that need
[Music]
our foundation is 41 years old 1977 it
was started and our first donation was
to the Boy Scouts of America because
when I was growing up scouting was very
important to me it was really my family
and then why did we start a foundation I
just thought with the time it was a good
idea it's not that I had a lot of money
I don't believe it's how much you have
but what you do with what you have my
father was a baker we lived above the
bakery as a family it was a difficult
existence I tell the story about when we
were in school and I only got one pair
of shoes each year and the shoes
couldn't cost more than five dollars
that was the rule of five dollars was a
pair of shoes I got pretty good
hitchhiking and I eventually wound up in
the Everglades and lived with the
Seminoles caught frogs sold the back
legs and ate the front legs I got along
pretty good
this is actually what it takes pictures
of the inside of the eye in the retina
this thing right here when I first
started my practice as an optometrist
ninety-eight percent of all the lenses
that were dispensed for eyeglasses
worked glass lenses the problem with the
plastic lenses it was clear and nobody
at that time knew how to color it so I
took it upon myself to learn how to
color plastic lenses that was the
beginning of our business our company
now makes over 4,000 products I've never
really had fear when I was Navy flying
planes you know yeah I had fear then but
day by day fear I usually don't have I
don't fear business I don't fear making
decisions and that's just as the
circumstances change I change I like my
sign out here now you're gonna see what
I call the Greybeards who were our first
deans of the university president
Alfonsin who was the president of
argentina at that time invited a group
of businessmen and university presidents
to come to Argentina to help them with
the economy we spent a week there
and that's when Mitch MIDI president of
Florida International University he said
to me how would you like to be part of
FIU I said if I come I'm gonna be doing
something I'm not gonna be sitting
around he says welcome to FIU and from
that day on we have been involved as the
chairman of the board of directors and
then two terms as trustee of the
University
we want is this to be a learning
community and being our learning
community they should focus around the
university that their seamless
each and every day you have so many
minutes so many hours and what are you
gonna do with them how are you gonna
express what you want to achieve in your
life and fortunately because of my
business it has been good to me and I'm
able to take the funds we have to take
my time and my ideas and be able to
extend them how are you and I see you
again
what are you in now third year you got
do my camera now too because I I don't
want to be left out yeah time is the
most important element you have yeah I
have a saying that we all have time in
common and we all have our humanity what
we do with those two things defines who
we are it's because of my humanity to
give back I don't know how to do it any
other way it's part of who I am
that's my legacy
[Music]
you